El Nino is one of the most well-known
modes of natural variability in the
climate system we see these modes of
natural variability where we have more
Heat going from the ocean into the
atmosphere that's during an El Nino or
more Heat going from the atmosphere back
into the ocean that's the opposite part
La Nina and it happens every few years
so every few years we go up into El Nino
then we go back into neutral for a year
or two and then we go down into La Nina
typically and then we go back up to
neutral and what that does is it affects
our weather around the world that's why
this matters to us because when we have
all that heat coming from the ocean into
the atmosphere during El Nino the globe
is a little bit hotter than average and
it also affects tropical regions
predominantly as well as we get a lot of
storms along the coastal area of North
America and they've even showed for
example that civil conflict in tropical
countries tends to increase during El
Nino years because of the impact of El
Nino on weather and the impact of
weather on people's livelihoods in the
economy